away from the poultry sheds that are the
focus of the UK's worst ever bird flu
outbreak wardens that the rspb's
minsmere reserve have been witnessing
the Insidious toll on Wildlife we've
seen quite a few unwell Barnacle geese
we've got one dead Barnacle goose in the
ditch right in front and on the island
behind a few days ago they got the news
they feared but expected these geese
were infected with highly pathogenic
h5n1 bird flu as we filmed a magpie came
to feed on one of the carcasses the
potential for spread from wild birds to
others clear to see
you know where we are at Men's mare we
know we have lots of neighbors who are
in the poultry business whether that's
big companies or small farmers with a
few turkeys and geese and they're all
incredibly worried
is this a tension that Wildlife can
afford right now certainly the answer is
not to blame the wild birds we know this
disease came out of intensive poultry
um production
um and you know it would be just crazy
to say yeah it's the wild birds fault
it's now clear that this highly
pathogenic strain of bird flu is now
permanently present endemic in our
wildlife and that changes everything and
means it's a disease that we can no
longer afford to ignore
can culling of poultry flocks remain an
ethical or sustainable way to control
the virus and while bird flu is
currently low risk to us it's closely
related to human flu I'm very surprised
that uh um given the recent history of
covid-19 that we are so complacent about
this virus which is spreading
more and more widely across the world
infecting poultry farms and thereby
having a lot of contact with humans
and yet we don't seem to be worried
about it
UK authorities have shifted up again the
animal and plant Health agencies leading
a Consortium to address the bird flu
challenge including potential risk to
people there's an awful lot of work
going on in that interface looking at
risk for humans indeed there have been
one or two cases but they've been very
mild infections this is an avian virus
that really wants to be in a bird house
rather than a mammal host but we need to
track that we need to Be watchful
they're working on how bird flu has
changed and developing better vaccines
for poultry
but nothing can help those in the wild
except perhaps acknowledgment that the
way we Farm has consequences
Tom Clark Sky News Suffolk